une visite d'état qui porte ses fruits
de l'asis bouteflika obtient de la
france la conversion en investissement
de la dette extérieure de l'algérie elle
s'élève à 28 milliards d'euros et
empêchait jusque là tout décollage de
l'économie le président algérien s'est
exprimé aujourd'hui devant le medef et a
appelé les entreprises françaises à
accroître leurs investissements ce soir
d aziz bouteflika était l'invité d'un
dîner débat au centre de conférences
avenue kléber à paris il abordait tous
les sujets qu'ils soient économiques ou
politiques les principaux extraits avec
audrey guinguette pourquoi finalement
les réformes vont aussi peu avancé dans
votre pays et à quels obstacles vous
êtes vous heurter nos patientes de
l'économie dirigé une économie de bureau
classique
à une économie de marché
l'économie de marché c'est une culture
c'est une culture que le peuple algérien
n'a pas
alors
passé de l'économie dirigée à l'économie
de marché c'est d'abord malheureusement
pas chez passer à l'économie de bazar
concernant les disparus durant la
période où vous n'étiez pas au pouvoir
quelle est votre position
la position de la concorde civile ça
passe par l'oubli ou par la vigilance de
la mémoire
si vous voulez ajouter un chapitre qui
s'appelle les disparus ou je ne sais
quoi ajouter ce que vous voulez mon
problème à moi
c'est de redresser la situation je ferai
tout ce qui doit être fait pour
réconcilier les algériens avec eux-mêmes
du sej mentir par omission